تمام
انا كده لايف ولا ايه لا لسه انا مش عندي
حاجه
اه ده انا على قناه تانيه
مزبوط كده
[موسيقى]
عذبنا الناس مساء الخير عذبنا حضراتكم
على التاخير ميعادنا كان تسعه ولكن بسبب
سياسه تخفيف الاحمال في القاهره
ومدن مصر انقطعت عنا الكهرباء اكثر مما
كان مقررا
اسفين جدا اسئله جاءت سريعا وبالتالي لا
وقت للتعليق على شيء الا اجابه اسئله
حضراتكم نبدا
بالصوره كويسه كله تمام يا ماندو
تحيه لك استاذنا العزيز انا حسن اذا حصلت
ايران على القنبله النوويه ماذا تستغير في
الشرق الاوسط يتغير الكثير يا استاذ احمد
امتلاك دوله للقنبله النوويه هي الالتمت
رادع هي الرادع الاكبر معناها انك لا
تستطيع ان تحارب هذه الدوله او تدخل معها
في مواجهه عسكريه هذا يعني انه ايران
اصبحت امنه تماما من اي هجوم عليها من
اسرائيل ايه هم عسكري يعني لكن الهجوم
الاقتصادي
تماما تتغير موازين القوه يصبح وجود
الولايات المتحده او
تهديدات اسرائيل يعني كلام في الهواء
عليك ان تتعامل معها باعتبارها قوه لا
يمكن ان تخضها حروب عسكريه لكن تسعى بقى
الى تقويضها بوسائل اخرى الامر الثاني انه
اذا وجدت دول الجوار انه ايران امتلكت
القنبله النوويه وتصرفت على انها دوله لا
تمس اتسعى دول اخرى لامتلاك القنبله
النوويه بلد زي تركيا بلد زي السعوديه
ممكن دول خارجيه اخرى بلد زي مصر قد تفكر
ايضا في امتلاك القنبله النوويه وهكذا
وتبقى مساله خطيره جدا
وكمان اسرائيل يعني هتبقى هتفقد الاحتكار
اللي بتتمتع به الان من امتلاك السلاح
النووي
مساء الخير استاذ سيد هل هناك امكانيه
لحدوث تصعيد كبير او ربما حرب روسيه
ايرانيه سوريه امريكيه
كرديه ام ان الضعيفه
بزيل الشكر على المجهود المحتوى شكرا انت
بتتكلم على الساحه السوريه يعني ساحه
السوريه
يعني
يعني لها وضع عجيب غريب لكن لانه احنا
انتهينا فقط من الحرب الساخنه كل الاطراف
بدات تسلم بالامر الواقع
واستقر الوضع على ما هو عليه نتيجه اه
صحيح نتيجه انتصار سوري ايراني روسي انما
في نفس الوقت على الاطراف الاخرى لكن في
نفس الوقت هذا الانتصار غير قادر على انه
يحقق استقرار لسوريا الاطراف التلاته ديت
قدرت تحقق مصر عسكري لكن غير قادره بحكم
امكاناتها وظروفها ان هي تعيد البلد على
قدميه مره اخرى
التوترات اللي موجوده بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده منعكسه على الوضع في سوريا طبعا
هل تتحول الى حرب اشك لان مين هيحارب مين
اذا كنت بتتكلم على حرب مباشره اظن يعني
امر بعيد جدا ان الروس يحاربه الامريكان
زي ما انت بتقول اذا كنت بتتكرر بتتكلم
على حرب بالوكاله فالحرب بالوكاله وصلوا
لاقساها واحنا عرفنا حدود الوكلاء ممكن
يوصلوا لفين والجانب المنتصر مازال قادر
على انه يكرر ده مره اخرى اذا كنا بنتكلم
على حرب بالوكاله على كل الاحوال لانه
التقديرات كثيره والاحتمالات كثيره
والامور بتتغير ردا على سؤالك استبعد ان
تكون هناك حرب كبيره يعني كما يوحي سؤالك
بين الاطراف التي ذكرتها
الفهر الفرات سامحني غلط تحياتي ربنا
يخليك ويحفظك
مرحبا استاذ سيد وعدتني في الحلقه الماضيه
ان تعطينا اسماء والله مكتوبه قدامي والله
انا فاكرها كويس افضل اسماء الكتب
والمواقع والقنوات على اليوتيوب لتعلم
الاقتصاد باحترافيه
وبالانجليزيه وارجو انتفي بوعدك ولا تقل
انت محدد سؤالك
فانه يعني
مش عارف
ايه يعني انت لو بتجيد اللغه الانجليزيه
يبقى انت ممكن تبدا مثلا
بتدي يعني تكتب كلمه وبعدين اللي هي
موسوعه الاستثمار اظنها بدايه جيده
للمبتدئين لانه بياخدك من موضوع الى موضوع
الى موضوع اكتبها دلوقتي وانا بكلم حضرتك
ممكن تكون بدايه جيده عندك كمان بلانس انا
بتكلم يعني موقع بلنس موقع جيد لانه بيقدم
برضو الامور من بدايتها بشكل كويس وبشكل
محترف اظن الاتنين دول ممكن يكونوا جيدين
اذا اردت حاجه بالعربي لا اعلم انه موجود
ولكن كتابات انا مش عارف برده حضرتك عاوز
تصدق من انهي مستوى ولكن في كتابات له
اساتذه كانوا بحكم كتابتهم بتتبسط وبتشرح
الامور ببساطه المرحوم الدكتور جلال امين
[موسيقى]
شرح كتاباته كتيره موجوده يعني وباللغه
العربيه الدكتور احمد جلال ربنا يدي له
الصحه والعافيه كتاباته المختصره اللي
موجوده في الجرايد ومقالاته وفيديوهاته
وبالمناسبه الفيديوهات ممكن تنفع بتشرح
كثير من اسس الاقتصاد ببساطه عندك لو عاوز
حاجه عميقه لو كانوا المستوى عميق ارشحلك
كتابات العالم الكبير
دكتور محمد دويدار
انا بعتقد انه واحد من اعظم العقول اللي
تحدثت في الاقتصاد
طبعا الاعلان بيتكلم عنه قليل جدا ده
الاسباب بطول شرحها يعني لكن كتابات
الدكتور محمد دويدار كتابات عميقه وعظيمه
جدا عندك
كمان
الدكتور ابراهيم عيسوي ربنا يدي له الصحه
والعافيه وعنده منهج وعنده تصور كويس جدا
يعني مختلف عن الافكار السائده
استاذنك علشان انا وعدت دي بدايه اهي ابدا
باللي انا قلته لو كان ده مش واضح
رجعني مره تانيه وبرضو انا كنت بس اللي
انا كنت ليه المساله بتاخد وقت انا كنت
عاوز فعلا اعمل احصاء لان انا عمري ما
فكرت اعملها يعني احصاء ليه المواقع
الاقتصاديه وكنت بحاول الاقي حاجه باللغه
العربيه يعني وبالمناسبه لو عندك حاجات
ملحه واسئله احنا مكملين في نعرف اقتصاد
للموضوعات التعليميه ابعتها لي استاذنك رد
عليا قل لي اذا كانت الاجابه دي مفيده ولا
لم تكن
مش فعلك نريد حلقه عن اقتصاد الجزائر
تستحق الجزائر حلقه عن اقتصادها وعن
سياستها حاضر ان شاء الله في اقرب فرصه
حاضر
استاذنا الكريم يوجد راي عام لدى الشعوب
العربيه ان الدول الخليج تابعه وليس لديها
تخطيط اليس
كان حالها حال فنزويلا اليس هناك تخطيط
على
صناديق الثروه ضخمه وبنا تحتيه محترمه
يعني انا فهمت من سؤالك ان انت بتستنكر
هذا الانطباع يعني
والله انا اعتقد ان هذا الانطباع لم يعد
دقيقا لا على دول الخليج ولا على دول
عربيه اخرى ونتحدثت في القصه ديت اكثر من
مره الانطباع السائد عندنا من فترات طويله
جدا انه الدول العربيه دي دول ستلايت
ستلايت يعني دول تابعه وان هي بتاخد
الاوامر بالتليفون وان هم بلا اراده وبلا
صوره قديمه الحقيقه هي بولغ فيها ولكن
الان على الاقل بقطع النظر انها بولغ فيها
وكانت صحيحه ام لا او منال لم تكن صحيحه
بالاساس يعني لانه لما بتقرا مذكرات
سياسيين قطار
سياسيين امريكان
كثيره يعني بتنفي الفكره دي بتقول فكره
الصوره اللي عندنا ان احنا
بنمشي الدول كانهم عرائس يعني فكره غير
سليمه
ولازم نفرق ما بين حاجتين ان دوله كبيره
دوله الدوله الاكبر في العالم اللي هي
الولايات المتحده او دول كبيره تانيه مش
لازم الولايات المتحده كلها تاثير وقدره
على ان هي تنجز مصالحها شيء وان الباقي
كله يكون عرائس ما هي الولايات المتحده لو
عندها مصلحه حيويه جدا يعني عاوزه شيء مش
عاوزه مثلا قاعده عسكريه في دوله معينه
عندها اعتراض حيوي جدا على قرار لا تريده
اذا ارادت شيء بهذا الشكل في الغالب
بتنفذه يعني بتنفزه على دول عربيه او
الدول غير عربيه لكن اذا كانت المساله
مساله حياه او موت يعني للدوله ديت ومساله
حيويه جدا صعب ان دوله ترفض قرار او اراده
لدوله كبيره لان العواقب هتكون خطيره جدا
ومش عاوز ادي امثله لانه يعني الامثله لا
تقع تحت حصر لما بيكونوا عاوزين حاجه
ومهمه جدا من اي دوله اوروبيه او من دوله
غير اوروبيه بيعملوه اذا كانت مساله خطيره
لكن في الغالب الامور كده وعموما ردا على
سؤالك لقى الدول الخليجيه والدول العربيه
انا المره اللي فاتت اتكلمت عن الجزائر
والمغرب وقدرتهم على معاقبه الدول
الاوروبيه
وقدرتهم على انه هم يقيدوا الدول المختلفه
على مصالحهم نفس القصه بالنسبه لدول
الخليج نفس القصه لدول في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط زي ايران وزي تركيا الصوره
باختصار غير صحيحه مبالغ فيها جدا يعني
او المشارك اتشرف بك صديقي يا ريت تكتب
اسمك
الحقيقي نتشرف به يعني علي مساء الخير
مساء الانوار استاذ سيد كم تحتاج وقت
لتعلم الاقتصاد جيدا وباحترافيه في زمن
قياسي وما هي الاشياء التي تنصحني بها
للتعلم ده اخونا نوب ايوه نوفو طب ما تكتب
اسمك يا اخونا بسرعه وكفاءه عاليه وما هي
الاخطاء التي يجب تجنبها والف شكر
الاقتصاد
يعني كلمه كبيره انت لازم تحدد هدفك من
تعلم الاقتصاد يعني انا لما اردت ان انا
ادرس اقتصاد وانا ما درستوش في الكليه انا
درست لان انا صحفي مهتمه بالعلاقات
الدوليه واردت ان انا ادرسه علشان اعمق
فهمي للامور كنت محدده ان انا صحفي عاوز
اتعلم اسس الاقتصاد اللي تخليني اقدر افهم
ما يجري في العالم انما في ناس تانيه لا
ده هو عاوز يدرس اقتصاد علشان مثلا يكون
فني او متخصص او مش عاوز استخدم كلمه خبير
يعني ايه او خبير زي مثلا في حساب التضخم
في حساب سعر الصرف في مثلا انه يكون بيعمل
ابحاث بيشتغل على قطاع الزراعه على قطاع
الصناعه على اي مجال من مجالات الاقتصاد
يعني فده محتاج حاجه تانيه خالص بيبقى نوع
تاني من المعرفه فانت بتحدد هدفك انت هدفك
انك تفهم ما يجري في العالم ده واحد هدفك
انك تحصل على وظيفه دي هتبقى حاجه تانيه
اي مجال من مجالات الاقتصاد بعد كده يتوقف
على الوظيفه اللي انت عاوزها او لو انت مش
عاوز وظيفه معينه يبقى انت هتسال ايه هو
المجال في الاقتصاد دلوقتي اللي ممكن يوفر
لي وظيفه احسن المساله تتوقف على هدفك
انما
الاجابه العامه اذا اردت ان انت تتعلم
اقتصاد قبل ما نوصل للاسئله ديت ويا ريت
توصل لها الاول لو ما كانش الاسئله دي
حاضره لغايه ما تقول لي عليها يعني
يبقى الافضل ان انت تفهم اسس الاقتصاد
العامه من المصادر واسمع وشارك واتعامل من
الاساتذه خير
الزائر رغم ان له علاقتها بالغرب جيده
ومعقوله ولكن لمجرد ان هي عاوزه تعمق
علاقتها مع هذه الدوله بيتم شيطنتها في
الكونجرس وفي اوروبا وهناك مطالبات
بمحاسبتها والحاق الاذى بها هذا هو السبب
اكثر
الاقتصاد باحترافيه وارجو ان تقوم بحلقه
كامله عن التداول تقصد ايه تداول الاوراق
الماليه تمدحنا معنا الدكتور مدفد الدكتور
مدحت نافع من اول سالته بقى في الدكتوره
كلها عام اسواق المال يعني بس بقول ده
سؤال مفتوح جدا لكن
سؤال على هذا النحو العام اذا انت فهمت
سؤالك فالاجابه المختص ان حضرتك مثلا يعني
معك 100 والمئه ديت مدختاجه للاكل واشرب
جزء صغير جدا من الارياف وليكن خمسه وليكن
اثنين تبدا بهم تداول من خلال مصدر تثق
فيه المبلغ ولا تنتظر
تبتدي تمشي المساله
لانه انت سوء المال ده الاسهم
فيه ارباح وفيه خسائر في اموالك مش مضمونه
وهتحتاج الى خبرات
هتستثمر هنا لن تستثمر هناك اذا استثمرت
هتستثمر على اي اساس طيب لما تيجي تاخد
قرارك بالاستثمار هتبص على انضمنتلز اللي
هو اساسيات الشركه اللي انت هتستثمر فيها
وهكذا تكتسب خبره لغايه ما تكتسب هذه
الخبره في اختيار الوسيط الذي تثق فيه او
في قليل جدا مما هو فائض عن حاجتك
[موسيقى]
العائد عليها بالشرط اللي انا قلته مرحبا
استاذ سيد الله يرحب بك ربنا يخليك بندر
نريد حلقه عن جيش الجزائر يا يوسف يعني
احنا محتاجين الحلقه عن الجزائر كلها يا
يوسف
احنا محتاجين حلقه عن الجزائر باذن الله
وخاصه ان التطورات كثيره جدا في الجزائر
وفي المغرب وفي شمال افريقيا حاضر يا
صديقي طيب انت لك
طيب بستلك
والله سامحني يا اخويا
شكرا مساء الخيرات هشام الجنينه الله
يخليك استاذ ما مستقبل سوريا يوسف
[موسيقى]
انا اسف يعني احنا سؤال كتير قبل كده ولكن
نامل خيرا جدا
السلام عليكم عليكم السلام اكرم من اقوى
من اقوى سياسيا وعسكريا واقتصاديا انجلترا
اولا ان ترى لو سرعتك بتقول انجلت منك لان
هي المملكه المتحده
هتزعل وويلز هتزعل القاربين يا صديقي لان
البلدين البلدين الصناعيين كبيرين
وبالمناسبه حتى الناتج المحلي الاجمالي او
الجدي قلت لكم من المحيط الى الخليج
البلدين عن بلدين الصناعيين البلدين عندهم
نفوذ كبير جدا سياسي
[موسيقى]
البلدين البلدين نوضح وضع فرنسا عامه افضل
بسبب خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي
اسلام مرحبا مرحبا مرحبا
كاليورانيوم
ده اخونا
نعطي اجابه تكون مختصره الى ان تطلبوا
المزيد من الاسئله استاذنكم اعملوا كده
بحث عن منطقه الساحل هي اسمها غريب الساحل
ملهاش علاقه قوي بالساحل الا اطرافها اذا
تخيلنا افريقيا افريقيا ممكن تقسمها لايه
شمال افريقيا الدول كلكم عارفينها اللي هي
المغرب وموريتانيا
والجزائر وتونس ومصر وليبيا ده الشمالي
يعني لما تنزل تحته شويه هتجد هي منطقه
الساحل الدول اللي تحت شاطئ المحيط
الاطلنطي ده في الغرب وتمشي شرقا كده الى
ان تصل الى السودان واريتريا جغرافيا لو
بصينا على الخريطه هتلاقوا منطقه الساحل
افريقيا عن الدول الجنوب لا معظم دول
افريقيا بقى بقيه الحاجه الخمسين ده
الجغرافيين ما بيقولوش كده بيقولوا ان
افريقيا ديت منطقه الشمالقيه الكبرى
والصحراء دي منقسم الى جزئين دول شمال
افريقيا اللي انتم عارفينها وفي جنوبها ما
يسمى بدول الساحل
باحث الجغرافيا انما من حيث على حسب لو
بتتكلم ساحل الجغرافيه بنتكلم على 10 دول
من السنغال
نتكلم على الدين من المشاكل بتنحصر تقريبا
في خمس دول
مالي نيجيري وممكن تضيف لها موريتانيا
نتكلم على اكثر هذه الدول اللي هي بقى محل
اهتمام العالم كله بنتكلم على ما يسمى
بالساحل سنترل ساحل او دايما لما نقول
الساحل بينصرف الذهن اليها لانها الاكثر
اضطرابا لانها الاكثر
توطينا او استقبالا او احتظاما للجامعات
المتطرفه جدا
واختصارا اختصارا للوقت يعني دول الساحل
الدول اللي انت عاوز تقوله يعني
لانه للاسباب التاليه واحد عندها ثروات
طبيعيه ضخمه جدا بما فيه اليوراني بالعرق
بتشير اليه اتنين لما الكبير بتكون في
منطقه الساحل بتقدر تسيطر على جحافل او
الطرق الهجره اللي عاوزه تطلع على اوروبا
تطلع على الشمال افريقيا دول شمال افريقيا
او انه الى اوروبا ثلاثه اللي هي موطن له
جماعات متطرفه استقرت واصبحت منطقه الساحل
هي اهم بقعه في العالم لتفريخ الجامعات
الارهابيه ليه دول الساحل بقت مرته على
الارهابيين والجريمه المنظمه والهجره دول
فاشله تقريبا او فقر شديد
فيما يتعلق بنيجر يعني
مستقره مقارنه بين الاخرين في منطقه
الساحل المركزي اللي هي
مالي بعدها اضطرابات من 2012 وبوركينا
فاسو الى لحقت بها وفي الثلاث سنين اللي
فاتوا كانت مستقره الى حد كبير
اصبحت هي تقريبا
الهضب او هي
الملاذ الاخير لفرنسا والدول الغربيه زي
الولايات المتحده ودول اخرى لا تبقى
موجوده في منطقه الساحل ولكن مع هذا
الانقلاب اصبح لم يعد هناك مكان لفرنسا
ولذلك هناك قتال من فرنسا حلفائه الغربيين
على تغيير الوضع في
احبك في الله ربنا يخليك يوسف اسعد الله
اوقاتك شكرا محمد استاذ سيد المحترم كيف
للولايات المتحده التفاوض مع السعوديه على
اتفاقيه دفاع مشترك مقابل الطبيعي لماذا
لا يجبرها على فعل ذلك لان الجيش السعودي
ضعيف والولايات المتحده من تحمل خليج من
ايران لا انت فاهم خالص يا استاذ محمد
ام ار اولا لو لو حتى لو افترضنا
انه يعني ازاي الولايات المتحده ازاي ممكن
تجبر السعوديه على التطبيع يعني لا احد
يستطيع ان يجبر الدوله على التطبيق لا
اللي افترض كله
استاذنك في انك تعيد النظر فيه اذا كنت
بتقول ان الولايات المتحده
هي اقوى من السعوديه طبعا هي اقوى من
السعوديه وهي اقوى من كل دول العالم بس
هذه القوه يعني
لها حدود لاستخدامها السعوديه دوله مستقله
عندها ادوات كثيره جدا
تمكنها في التعامل مع الولايات المتحده هي
كل تعاون ليست حرب يعني الولايات المتحده
والسعوديه او الولايات المتحده واي دوله
اخرى في العالم في اي تعامل المساله ليست
ان انا عندي قدرات عسكريه استطيع ان امحك
من على الوجود ولكن بما اننا لن نمحو بعض
من على الوجود وبما انه الخيار العسكري
يعني انت برا المساله ففي مصالح السعوديه
قادره بامكانياتها زي الدول الاخرى ان هي
[موسيقى]
يعني تتفاوض وتساوم السعوديه انت عاوزاني
اطبع مع اسرائيل وانا ما ليش مصلحه مباشره
في التطبيع اذا اذا اردتيني ان انا اطبع
انا ليه مطالب واحد اتنين تلاته اشرت لهم
في حلقه امس وفي حلقات سابقه طيب امريكا
تقول لها طيب والله انت عاوزه مني ثلاث
مطالب صعبه جدا انت عاوزه سلاح انت عاوزه
برنامج نووي سلمي وانت عاوزه
اتفاقيه الدفاع مشترك وانت عاوزه ايه
الطلب الثالث
[موسيقى]
ذكروني شباب
اتفاق الدفاع المشترك اه وعاوزه اسلحه
متقدمه اللي هو يعتبر تكمله للدفاع
المشترك ده علشان مقابل التطبيع فقط لا مش
كفايه ما انت هتستفيدي اسرائيل دي دوله
متقدما على زملك كمان ما هو اكثر جمدي
علاقاتك بالصين ويخليها علاقات محدوده
كملي تعاونك مع روسيا وخصوصا فيما يتعلق
بالنفط
راعينا في مساله اسعار البترول وهكذا
وعليه فالمساله بتبقى مفاوضات هل
المفاوضات تنجح او لا ما هي عمليه صعبه
جدا ومعقده صعبه على السعوديه وصعب على
الامريكان
وبالتالي المساله اخذ ورد يعني ليس كما
تتخيل لو كانت المساله بالشكل ده ما كانش
فيه ولا دوله رفضت اي مطلب للولايات
المتحده يعني ما كانتش ايران رفضت مطالب
الولايات المتحده في الاخر ايران لن تقارن
لو بنتكلم على القوه الخاشنه لن تقارب
بالولايات المتحده يعني
استاذ سيد ما هي افضل الطرق للربح في
الاقتصاد
والبورصه او التداول ولا تحتاج وقت
لتعلمها لا لا سامحني لا اعلم هذا نوع من
الاسئله يا صديقي النصائح بالاستثمار لا
يعني ليست مجال يعني اذكر اسمي بليز عبد
المعطي عبد الله هاشم تشرفنا بيك عبد
المعطي عبد الله هاشم
اجبنا اجبنا اخ سيد النظام البنك المصرفي
المصرفي لكل من درسه بعمق واضح انه ما في
قانون
وتحايل مالي وخلق الماء من الهواء برايك
لماذا الناس لا تثور تفور على ايه على
النظام المصرفي نظام المصرفي يعني هو قطع
حساس جدا وفيه بيحتكر مدخرات الناس كل
واحد معه فلوس يعني ما لم يكن لديه قروش
قليله يعني هو مضطر للتعامل مع البنك حتى
لو عنده خروج قليله هو موظف في شركه ولا
كذا فالشركه بتحول له عن طريق البنك ومع
تطور الوقت هيزيد الاحتياج للبنوك لانه
الدول بتحارب ان تبقى الاموال خارج الجهاز
المصرفي حتى تستطيع مراقبتها وعليه لما
بتيجي تدفع مبلغ صغير في اي مكان يقول لك
والله اعمل لي تحويل بنك زي ما بيحصل فيه
الدول الكبيره
بما ان الاموال كلها بتصب في البنوك
فالبنوك بتحاول ان هي تستثمرها وبتحاول
تستثمرها بالطرق التي تدر عليها عائد على
البنوك وعلى موظفيها وليس بالضروره على
البلد ايه نعمل ايه الناس تصور الناس
المساله مش محتاجه ثوره المساله محتاجه
انه كل دوله من خلال مشرعيها
يحاولوا ان هم
يتعاونوا اوجه الخطا والتجاوز وده جاري
يعني طول الوقت في اخطاء من الجهاز
المصرفي بيتم تداركها من اجهزه الرقابه
البنوك بتعمل امور تانيه تجاوزات تانيه
بتتحايل على القانون علشان تعظم مكاسبها
والمساله مش في البنوك بس اصل هو دايما
صراع تضارب المصالح الكلام ده بيتعلق بكل
الاجهزه الدوله باسواق المال
بالمزارعين بالمصنعين بالاجهزه الاعلام كل
واحد بيحاول يعظم مكاسبه بالتحايل على
القانون والقانون وبيتم يعني
تدارك يعني يتم ضبطهم فينضبطوا ثم يبحثوا
عن وسائل اخرى وهكذا نريد تقريرا شاملا
عما يحدث في سوريا في شرق الفرات والله
عندي لقاء مع
صديق يعني مهتم جدا صحفي
مطلع على المساله وكنت ان شاء الله امل
انه ينقل لي صوره ادق شويه عما يجري هناك
هو المساله جريت بس ان شاء الله نرجع تاني
هل زراعه القمح صعبه حتى تحتكر روسيا
واوكرانيا زراعته ويضع العالم يده على
قلبه من توقف شحنات القمح بسبب الحرب لا
زراعه القمح ليست صعبه ولكن عشان تزرع قمح
تزرعه فين يعني
احنا بنتكلم على العالم العربي دلوقتي ما
انت عشان تزرع قمح انت محتاج مساحات
زراعيه ومحتاج كميات وفيره من المياه
فضلا بقى عن الامكانيات الماليه فانت انت
عندك شح مائي في العالم العربي وهذا الشح
المائي العالم العربي كل افريقيا دي كل
افريقيا ده فضلا عن اسيا يعني يعني انت
بتتكلم على شبه الجزيره العربيه والعراق
وسوريا وايران بيعانوا من جفاف شديد جدا
نفس القصه بتنطبق على الدول العربيه كل
شمال افريقيا ده واقع في منطقه الصحراء
اللي كنت بقول لحضرتكم عليها منطقه
الصحراء الافريقيه اللي هي اكبر صحراء
حاره في العالم
بتتميز بالصحراء بتتميز بالجفاف بشح
المياه فانت علشان تزرع قمح اتحتاج مساحات
زراعيه كبيره لا تتوفر لدول محتاج اراضي
مناسبه لا تتوفر في الدول في معظم الدول
محتاج مساحات كميات كبيره من الامطار
عندنا شح مائي وبعدين في امور بقى تانيه
ثانويه لما يكون عندك مساحات مياه مساحات
اراضي محدوده وشح مائي وعندك اقتصاد حر
مزارعين يحق لهم ان يزرعوا ما شاؤوا هو
بيختار العائد الاكبر وبما انه المساحه
قليله على عكس مثلا بلد زي روسيا اوكرانيا
يقدر يزرع كميات كبيره وعنده اراضي خصيبه
اخرى متاح للمزارعين ان هم يوجهوها الى ما
ارادوا يعني يعني الاجابه باختصار مساحات
زراعيه محدوده شحميه
مساء الخير استاذ سيد اتمنى لك الصحه
والعافيه امين يا رب لينا وليك ولكل الناس
ان شاء الله تكلمت عن عيوب الجغرافيا
الروسيه ممكن تتكلم عن مميزات وعيوب
الموقع الجغرافي للسعوديه بالخصوص
للخليج العربي والبحر الاحمر اتكلمنا عن
السعوديه يا اخونا جي اتش اتش السعوديه
عندها مساحه ضخمه اظنها يعني
تتجاوز ايه يعني بتقترب من الاتنين مليون
كيلو متر مربع الرقم مش حاضرنا يعني هي
طبعا اصغر من الجزائر اللي هي اكبر بلد من
حيث المساحه انما مساحه ضخمه السعوديه
والمساحه الضخمه ديت ليست في الهواء الطلق
هي عندها اطلاله كبيره جدا على البحر
الاحمر هي عندها القدره بحيث ان العمق
الدولي المجاوره مش مش حاجز لها يعني
عندها قريب تقدر تستغل موانئ الدول الاخرى
في سلطنه عمان وكل الدول المطله على
الخليج العربي
الجغرافيا ما بتشملش بس الاطلاله
الجغرافيا بتشمل المساحه الكبيره ديت فيها
فيها الاماكن الشديده الحراره وفيها
الاماكن المعتدله اللي بتبوس بتطل على
البحر الاحمر او في المرتفعات عندها ثروات
طبيعيه ضخمه وبالتالي اه يعني ربنا حمل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بموقع ثري يعني
يعني احنا بنعيش على امل انه الهدوء اللي
حصل النسبي الهدوء الحذر ما بين الايران
والسعوديه نامل انه ينعكس بشكل اكبر من
مجرد التهدئه اللي موجوده في اليمن تسالني
عن رايي
يعني انا ما عنديش حاجه تدعوني الحياه
للتفاؤل على المدى المنظور يعني اتمنى ان
ربنا يخيب ظن يعني لان انا اللي انا شايفه
كده يعني انه اقسم ما يمكن ان تفعله الدول
الكبيره واتمنى ان هم يسيبوا اليمن في
حالها وده مستحيل يعني ده في الاحلام لكن
اقسم ما يمكن ان تفعله السعوديه ان هي
تؤمن حدودها باتفاق مع الحوثيين فتضمن
استقرارها بس وفي الحاله ديت هتبقى يعني
واذا بقى الهدوء مع ايران يبقى ايران لن
تسعى الى استغلال الجنوب يعني قصدي الجبهه
الجنوبيه للسعوديه والحوثيين لن يمسوا به
المملكه والمملكه لن تمس بهم لكن هيبقى
المشكله الكبيره جدا ماذا يفعل الحوثيين
مع باقي القرى قوه وماذا تفعل باقي القوى
مع الحوثيين احنا كده يعني امنا مصالحنا
كسعوديين او ايرانيين لكن ماذا عن القوى
اليمنيه صعب قوي انه في قوه خارجيه وصعب
اكتر انه من الداخل هذه القوه اليمانيه
المتناثره تستطيع ان هي تحقق السلام فيما
بينها
في الوقت الحالي على الاقل
سلام عليكم استاذ سيد قبل كل حاجه اشكرك
على امانتك وحيادتك في ارائك السياسيه مصر
رايحه فين هل تتوقع ثوره قريبا ولو حصل
ثوره هل ممكن ان يتخلى الجيش عن الحكم
بسهوله ابو ادم ده سؤال فوري يا ابو ادم
لا يعني حكايه ثوره يعني اعتقد ان دي
عامله زي السؤال اخر من اخ لينا كان
بيتكلم عن علاقه السعوديه بامريكا فيه
الكثير من التقدير يعني يعني في كثير من
الدراميه يعني مصر عندها مصاعب ماليه
مصاعب اقتصاديه واحد انه علشان نشوف
الصوره بامانه المصاعب التي يعانيها
الاقتصاد المصري ليست خاصه بالاقتصاد
المصري يعني مش العالم كله عايش في رغد
ومصر بس اللي عايش ازمه اقتصاديه مصر تعيش
ازمه اقتصاديه كواحده من عشرات الدول التي
تعيش ازمات اقتصاديه فده يجب ان يكون
واضحا في حاله عدم رضا في حاله كذا كبرته
للامانه الحكومه المصريه ليست هي الحكومه
الوحيده التي يعني
يعني تعاني من عدم
شريحه كبيره من الناس ضدها
الوضع في المصري يحتاج الى اداره جيده
تقلها من عثرتها وليس ثوره لانك يعني
الثوره دي يعني
وبالتالي ما نامله وما اتمناه وما اتوقعه
لا مش ما اتوقعه ما امله انه الحكومه
باعتبار ان الحكومه هي اللي بتعمل كل حاجه
من اول فصل الكهرباء علينا من غير ما
بلغنا ايه اللي بيحصل الا ان هي اللي
بتعقد الاتفاقات وده اكبر مشكله عند
الحكومه ان هي ماضيه او يعني اخذه فيما
تريد دون اخذ راي اي حد يعني هم بيقولوا
بناخد هم غير سليم يعني غير سليم يعني كل
الجهات كلها مسخره للموافقه على القوه
التنفيذيه يعني البرلمان بيوافق يعمله
الحكومه مفيش حد في البرلمان ابدا بيقول
لا الاعلام وظيفته الاساسيه ان يبارك ما
تفعله الحكومه الاحزاب ليس لها دور
الحكومه ثم الحكومه ثم الحكومه الحكومه
سعت لده السلطه التنفيذيه ساعات لنا والان
هي
بتعاني مما سعت اليه لو كانت الامور
يعني وزعت بشكل معتدل شويه الحكومه ما
كانتش هتواجه كل هذه الصعوبات لان كان
هيبقى كل مؤسسه بتقوم بدورها بشكل معقول
يعني انما انا وان ده حصل اتمنى انه
يدركوا انه البلد لا تستطيع ان تقوم فقط
على حكومه او شخص او شخصين وانه اي بلد اي
بلد حتى لو كان صغير فما بالكم ببلد كبير
يحتاج لكل المؤسسات تعمل وتعمل بحريه مش
من قبيل ان تسمع الرئيس او رئيس الحكومه
ما يرضى وانه يكون في مناخ اكثر انفتاحا
تسمع فيه كل الاصوات
وعشان تسمع كل الاصوات هيبقى في ناس مش
فاهمه بتتكلم وفي ناس لها مصالحهم ده
طبيعي يعني ده في كل مكان انما في وسط
الاصوات ديت هيكون في الادوات هتندق وانه
البرلمان يسفر لو في حريه انه ياتي بعناصر
اكثر فاعليه ان الاعلام يتفتح فيجيب ناس
اكتر غير
الناس اللي هي وظيفتها بس انه بيبذل جهد
ليل ونهار انه يزون كلام اللي بتقوله
الحكومه فالامور تبقى احسن والثقه في
القرارات تبقى اكتر
وهكذا فما نحتاجه ليس ثوره يا اخونا محتاج
ان احنا يعني نعدل الخلل الذي اصابنا لا
اكثر ولا اقل هزمه اعتقد وما اتمناه
السلام عليكم انا جابر من السعوديه هل
ستتوقف الولايات المتحده واوروبا عن دعم
اوكرانيا مع زياده ضغط الاقتصادي على هذه
الدول وهل سيكون هذا سيناريو نهايه الحرب
والله وارد جدا يا جابر
جدا جدا لان كمان مع انتخابات 2024 هتحصل
انتخابات في دول متعدده والحكومات مش
بالضروره يعني التي سوف تاتي هيكون لها
نفس حماس هذه الحكومات ممكن الولايات
المتحده كل حاجه تتغير اذا ذهب هذا الى
بيته يعني وجاء رئيس اخر اذا جاء ترامب
مثلا ربما تتغير الامور كثيرا لانه شعوب
كثيره واحزاب كثيره بتسال ما جدوى هذه
الحرب وانا لو اتكلمت على الاسر ممكن
اتكلم اسابيع يعني فنعم ممكن يعني الاجابه
نعم هذا وارد وقد يكون هذا احد
السيناريوهات التي تؤدي الى
يعني وقف العدائيات داود هل هناك مخطط
لتغيير الديموغرافي في سوريا هل يعتبر
هجره السوريين من سوريا لها اي منفعه
بالنسبه للدول المتنازعه في سوريا
يعني
ماذا يستفيد من يستفيد من المعده يعني لا
اعلم بذلك
شكرا استاذ سيد على حلقاتك الجميله حلقتك
حلقاتك ساعدتني في دراسته ممكن تتكلم في
يوم عن اقتصاد البيئه
ممكن تحدد السؤال اكثر ماذا تريد من
اقتصاد البيئه لان اقتصاد البيئه ده كلمه
كبيره جدا
اذا وافتني بالسؤال قد اساعد ما اخر
مستجدات مشروع الديانه الدوله الابراهيميه
فارس والله يعني
والله لحسن الحظ يعني الحمد لله انه كان
يعني استضافتنا لصاحبه هذا البحث الباحث
المميزه الدكتوره هبه جمال الدين في اربع
حلقات متواليه فضلا انا اتكلمت عنها في
حلقه اخرى ثم في بعض الجرائد التي كنت
اعمل فيها يعني
اظن ده ادى الى انتباه الكثيرين من رؤساء
الدول وسياسييننا وكتاب
والى هذا
المخطط يعني وبالتالي على الوقت الحالي
الناس منتبهه اليه
[موسيقى]
واصبحوا اكثر ادراكا منه يعني اكيد دائما
في الاخر ايه هدف يعني التصور فكره انه
يبقى في مشروع يمكن اسرائيل من قياده
المنطقه والسيطره عليها ده متعدد الاشكال
اذا تعثر مسار تبقى في مسارات اخرى يعني
في حد عاوز حلقه عن الاقتصاد الجزائري حد
عاوز حلقه عن الاقتصاد المغربي
ان شاء الله
اكرم
شكرا يا اكرم على القلوب الجميله كثر خيرك
مساء الخير هل سبق بالتاريخ لنظام دكتور
ان سقد بحصار اقتصادي فقط
نظام ديكتاتوري سقط بحصار اقتصادي فقط
والله محتاج اتذكر بس ممكن يعني
[تصفيق]
محتاج ان انا
يعني افكر شويه انما ما فيش حاجه غريبه
خالص انه
انه يعني يتم
وضع الدوله تحت ضغط اقتصادي عنيف حتى يضج
من حول الحكومه
[موسيقى]
وتضعف وتسقط يمكن
محتاج ان انا افكر اكتر يعني علشان نجيب
على سؤالك بشكل جيد السلام عليكم استاذ
سيد قبل اجبت
اجابنا كواشي يسال جبيل ما هي مصدر قوه
فرنسا
دوله منتهيه ونفوذها بالي ممكن توضح لنا
مصدر القوه للدوله الفرنسيه يا اخونا
قواشي لا بقى برضو ده سؤال عامل زي بعض
السؤال يعني المبالغه شويه يعني او
الافتراض انت بتفترض نتيجه على
على فرد بالسليم يعني بترتب نتيجه على فرد
من السليم يعني فرنسا لم تعد الامبراطوريه
التي كنا نعرفها قبل الحرب العالميه
الاولى وفي القرن ال19 وفي القرن ال 18
وفي القرن ايوه ده صحيح ولكنها تظل انسى
للتعبيرات الفضفاضه قوه عظمى وقوه منهاره
بالارقام بس زي ما بقول لحضرتك انت لما
تيجي تفكر في فرنسا كده تلاقي ان ده
اقتصاد هم عدد سكانهم حوالي
60 65 مليون معلش حد ممكن الدقهلي في
الارقام يعني على ده هيكون في الحدود دي
في حدود 60 مليون يعني طيب الستين مليون
دول الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لهم حوالي
اثنين وسبعه من عشره تريليون دولار الرقم
طبعا بيتغير يزيد قليلا يقل قليلا على حسب
السنه
فده رقم ضخم انا كنت لسه بقول لحضرتك ده
يعني مش اقل بكتير من اقتصاد افريقيا كله
يعني
بلد غني جدا عنده بالنسبه بمعيار الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي دوله غنيه من اكبر
اقتصادات العالم هي دوله نوويه هي دوله
صناعيه كبرى بتصنع صناعات حرجه وحساسه هي
دوله زراعيه من الطراز الاول بتنتج سلع
كثيره ومتطوره والزراعه السلعه بيعتبروها
امن قومي في فرنسا زي الدول الكبرى هي
دوله
عندها من دول الخمسه اللي عندها حق الفيتو
في مجلس الامن هي دوله عندها علاقات وثيقه
جدا جدا بمعظم مستعمراتها السابقه
واستطاعت بسياستها انه رغم خروجها لما اجر
مثلا او غيرها او دول شمال المغرب انها
تربط هذه الدول بها وبلغتها الفرنسيه
وبثقافتها وان هذه الدول تستثمر في فرنسا
او فرنسا تستثمر فيها يعني دوله قويه
كبيره مهمه ان الناس تهفوا قلوبها انها
تروح الى فرنسا والسياحه لفرنسا العائد من
السياحه الفرنسيه الدخل دول كامله يعني
جامعتها تعليمها
السلام عليكم
برايك بيض
ما رايك بفتره بايدن الرئاسيه حتى الان
سؤال كبير عام ولكن لازم نحدده يعني من
استفاد ومن تضرر انت لازم تسال بالنسبه
لامريكا ولا بالنسبه لي منطقه الشرق
الاوسط مين في منطقه الشرق الاوسط انما
انا تصوري يعني طبعا ده سؤال عام وهيكون
بصراحه يعني دايما من الحاجات اللي هتحتمل
عامله زي الفيل الكبير اللي كل واحد بيصفه
والعميان اللي كل واحد بيحاول يصفه من
تلمسه يعني ولكن سواء بيضا او سواء ترامب
كلاهما بيعبر عن ازمه بيعيشها الولايات
المتحده انه الولايات المتحده
هي نفسها في ازمه واصبحنا احنا كدول
متاثره بمن يدخل البيت الابيض احنا بنعيش
في عصر سياسيين او رؤساء ولايات يعني
رؤساء امريكان بيقودوا امريكا ماذونه يعني
لك ان تتخيل كالاتي
الرئيس ترامب ضرب بعرض الحائط ضرب بكل
قوانين العالم عرض الحائط ما فيش افتراء
اكثر من كده يقول لك انا خلاص انا موافق
مثلا على انه اراد الجولان دي اراضي خلاص
اراضي اسرائيليه ما فيش قانون بيقول كده
ما فيش اي حليفه ممكن اراضي سوريه مش
بتاعتك فما تقدرش تغيرها بجرد قلم هو مش
مهتم باي قانون خالص انه انا هقسم المسائل
دي القدس خلاص انا اعترفت بالقدس طب ما ده
ضد كل القوانين انما انا ما عنديش مشكله
في القصه ديت هو راجل
تصرفاته كلها
مثيره للجدل
يعني صعب انه يكون على راس السلطه في
الولايات المتحده الناس تنفسني الصعداء
وقالوا هيجي رئيس اكثر اتزانا الرئيس
الاكثر اتزانا مستعد ان يقاتل لاخر لحظه
في اوكرانيا مخاطره بحرب عالميه مع روسيا
مع الصين دون هدف واضح تستفيد منه باقي
الدول قد يرى انه عنده فايده هو ما فيهوش
فايده على المدى البعيد ولكن بيعرض العالم
كله لخطر بجد ده مجموعه من المتطرفين في
الحزب الديمقراطي مستعد ان تذهب بالحروب
لفرض اجنده من الحريات بالغه التطرف في
حقوق الاجهاض والمثليه الجنسيه والتحول
الجنسي وخلى ادارته كلها عباره عن خليط من
يعني اتكلمنا عن القصه دي كتير فانا بعتقد
انه هم حتى في امريكا بيقولوا احنا
محتاجين طرف فارس لا الجمهوريين بوضعهم
اللي بيزداد تطرفا يوما بعد يوم ولا
الديمقراطيين اللي برضو اصبح عندهم جناح
بالغ التطرف هل اردوغان يسعى لتحسين
العلاقات مع الاسد كما كانت قبل
الانتخابات اردوغان بيسعى لتحسين العلاقات
مع كل من حوله للعوده
بسياسته الى اقل قدر من المشاكل ولكن
الخلافات والتناقضات مع الاسد تخلي الامر
يصعب ممكن يحسنها مع مصر يحسنها مع دول
الخليج التناقضات قليله لكن مع الاسد
التناقضات كبيره سيدنا
لا سامحني انا مش عارف يعني مش عارف اقرا
بتقول عليه يعني انا سامع سيدنا
طيب يمكن دي حاجه باللهجه بقى مثل مغربي
يعني لو هو وضحته لي بالشكل اثر شويه ممكن
افهمه
اجابنا
ماذا يعني وصف ملك المغرب في خطابه الاخير
ان العلاقات المغرب والجزائر بانها علاقات
مستقره رغم ان الحدود البريه اكثر من 30
سنه بالاضافه الى غلق المجال الجوي
والبحري وقتل العلاقات الدبلوماسيه والله
انا برضو كنت بسال هذا السؤال استاذنكم بس
لحظه
انا كنت بسال هذا السؤال هو الشاحن بس كان
يبدو ان انا نسيت احطه في الكهرباء
والصاله بالكهرباء
هو يعني ما في شك ان العلاقات
[موسيقى]
يعني نرجع شويه العلاقات بين البلدين
السيئه ما في شك فيها
هم بيقولوا الشعبين ده اكيد ولكن في شريحه
هنا وشريحه هناك ايضا متطرفه كل منهم تجاه
الاخر
ودي ليست ظاهره عجيبه ولا غريبه لان في
شعوب بتكون متقاربه ولكن الحساسيات بينهم
كلما تقاربوا كلما كانت الحساسيات بينهم
كثيره في حساسيه بين المصريين والسودانيين
رغم انه هم كانوا بلدنا واحدا في حساسيه
ما بين اوكرانيا وروسيا ورغم ان هم وممكن
تضيف لهم كمان بيلاروس رغم ان هم كانوا
بلدا واحد وعرقيه واحده الى اخره ودين
واحد ده مش حاجه غريبه يعني سياسيا ولا
تاريخيا
لكن
ماشي كده بين المغرب وان المغرب يكون
بيتخذ خطاب
سياسي هادئ وتكون الجزائر بتتاخد خطاب
سياسي زاعق
انما للخطاب الهادئ المغرب بيطمئن
الجزائر ولا الخطاب الزاعق
للمغرب
بيضيف لي العلاقات بيحسن من العلاقات
ويدفعهم ان هم يتفاهموا يعني كلاهما ما
بيغيرش من الواقع
الواقع ان الخلافات بين البلدين كبير جدا
انا هرد على سؤالك
وانه كل ما يمكن قطعه تقريبا قطع زي ما
حضرتك اشرت كده انما لما ملك المغرب بيقول
كده ربما يقصد ده جزء من الخطاب الناعم
العام للمملكه المغربيه اللي عاوزه تهدي
الاجواب ويقول ان احنا لسنا على شفى حربا
يعني كما توحي بعض التصريحات او التحليلات
وانه
يعني ان في امل في العلاقات تعود مش عارف
تعود لايه تعود الى الفترات القليله اللي
كانت العلاقات فيها على المستوى الرسمي
طيبه اعتقد هذا ما يقصده والا ما فيش
تفسير تاني لانه زي ما انت بتقول العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مقطوعه من 2021
العلاقات التجاريه مجمده
العلاقات
الثقافيه الرياضيه ما لم يكن حدث مجبرين
على المشاركه في
البلدين طوال الوقت كل واحد يعني سياسته
الخارجيه مبنيه تقريبا عكس الاخر يعني
هل تتوقع ان المصلحه السعوديه والايرانيه
سوف تستمر مصالحه لا لا اعتقد اعتقد ان
التوتر قائم يعني السلام عليكم انا جابر
اجابتي يا صديقي جابر
هل مقوله كلما تسلحت المانيا تحصل حرب
عالميه صحيحه
في الماضي يعني
في الماضي طبعا لانه انت المانيا انت عندك
في القرن 19
حروب
بمجرد ما توحرت المانيا 1870
حروب مع كل الدول اللي حولها الدنمارك
فرنسا
الف وتسعمائه واربعتاشر 1939
ايوه من يعني
تاريخيا كان هذا سليم
هل ممكن ده يبقى في المستقبل ممكن نعم
وممكن لا ما رايك في الوضع الاقتصادي
والسياسي في تونس بعد اقاله رئيسه الحكومه
وتعيين رئيس جديد
يعني تفتكر هي المشكله كانت في رئيسه
الحكومه يعني
المشكله في تونس زي مشكله في دول اخرى انه
الشعوب والقوه اللي موجوده النخب مشغوله
الاول
مشغول الاول بالصراعات السياسيه يعني مين
ياتي الى السلطه ياتي النهضه ياتي من معه
ياتي من هو ضد النهضه ياتي الحين دول
مشغولين الاول بمن ياتي الى السلطه اولا
ودي برضه مش حاجه غريبه الانشغال الشديد
جدا او عدم الاتفاق والخلافات العنيفه بين
النخب السياسيه في بلد ما بتخلي
الاعتبارات الاقتصاديه اولويه ثانيه
وثالثه ورابعه وخامسه
الى ان تستقر الامور ويكون في اجماع من
النخب اللي موجوده على ان من يتولى الامر
الرئيس قيس سعيد او غيره يعني انه بيحظى
باكبر قدر ممكن من دعم المؤسسات والدوله
وعدم العرقله وتستقر الامور وتاتي السياحه
وتذهب الصادرات والمجتمع الدولي يثق فيهم
ويبتدي يدي تمويل وقروض المساعدات تغيير
رئيس الحكومه قد يؤثر ولكن مش بشكل كبير
على الاحتياطي الضخم للفوسفات المغربي
يعطي للدوله المغربيه قوه على المستوى
الاقتصادي طبعا
الفوسفات هو مكون رئيسي
في صناعه الاسمده والاسمده يعني الزراعه
والعالم كله بيعاني من
نقص الاغذيه الرئيسه
نعم هل ما رايك في خطاب محمد السادس
المتناقض مع الواقع ونفيه وجود مشكله من
الاساس مع الجزائر في الوقت نفسه يدعو
نتنياهو لزياره المغرب وما اثرت اسرائيل
لملحق عسكري في منطقه شمال افريقيا
بالنسبه للجزء بتاع الخطاب الملك محمد انا
قلت تفسير الوحيد انه يعني جزء من خطاب
عام للمغرب بانه الامور هادئه وندعوكم الى
يعني
عاده السياسيين المغاربه بيتحدثوا هكذا
انما
انما المشكله موجوده
بتقول حضرتك انه دعوه اي دعوه من المغرب
واي علاقات بتتعاظم بين المغرب واسرائيل
بالضروره تؤدي الى تاجيك العلاقات او سوء
العلاقات بين الجزائر والمغرب يقينا يقينا
يقينا يعني
في جزء من السؤال الجزء الثالث من سؤالك
بيصب في كذا انه لما اسرائيل تعترف
بمغربيه او بصياده المغرب على الصحراء هذا
ايضا يؤجج العلاقات ويشعلها يرضي المغرب
ولا يرضي الجزائر لكن لما تاتي يكون اول
قرار لاسرائيل اللي هي بتعلن عدوتها
للجزائر ويعني
او على الاقل يعني هم في حاله خصوبه في
الجزائر لا تعترف باسرائيل يكون اول قرار
لاسرائيل بعد الاعتراف بسياده المغرب على
الجزائر هو ارسال ملحق عسكري هذه ايضا
رساله تقلق الجزائر انه نبرم صفقات
والسفقات ديت تبقى صفقات سلاح اسرائيلي
متطور درونز واستطلاع واستكشاف واستهداف
وتجسس كل دي امور تقلق الجزائريين
ما رايك في خطاب مساء الخير استاذنا
الفاضل مساء الخير
لماذا تطرح البنوك المركزيه لدول الخليج
سندات بنكيه بفوائد مثلما تفعل امريكا رغم
انها تنتمي لدول تحقق فائده كبير من عواد
البترول هذه قصه بسيطه يا استاذنا انا
دوله انا انا راجل اعمال انت بتشوف ناس
عندهم بلاش دول عندهم مليارات من
الدولارات وبيقترض من البنوك ليه بيقترب
من البنوك هو يقول لك انا اموالي مستثمره
يعني دوله خليجيه عندها
الفائض ده ذهب الى شراء اصول طيب هي مش
عاوزه تحتاج الى اموال بتقارن قرار انا
اخد الاموال ديت
يعني لو انا محتاج اسيل اصولي ولا اقترض
بفائده محدوده بما ان انا محل ثقه ممكن
بيلاقي الحسبه ببساطه انه الافضل له انه
يقترض زي مثلا بفائده مثلا يعني خمسه او
سته في الميه على انه يسيء لاصوله ويخسر
ارباح اكثر
اعتبارات مختلفه كثيرا الدول الغنيه
بتقترض زي الاثرياء ما بيقترضوا لان
احيانا بالحساب يكون القرض اسهل
يعني افضل ليه يعني اقل تكلفه من انه من
الفرص اللي ممكن يستغل فيها الفائض امواله
مستقبل العلاقات الفرنسيه الافريقيه سؤال
كبير لكن حتى الان سؤال كبير انا اشرب
مياه انت مش مسموع لك تشرب ما انت مش
ده ماندو بقى قاعد جنب المصيف
وخد الميه بتاعتي مش كفايه ان هو سابنا
فرنسا
بتتراجع نفوذها يوم بعد يوم
في دول افريقيا وبصراحه هو تراجع تاخر
كثيرا لانه فرنسا يعني على قديمه العالم
بيتغير وانت المفروض كمان تغير ممارساتك
في هذه الدول مش معقوله كل اللي يهمك في
دول الساحل وافريقيا انك تمنع تضرب
الارهاب عندهم اللي هو ناتج عن الفقر
بالدرجه الاولى
وعن دعمك لانظمه هي برضو فاسده وكذا
وعاوز تقيم قواعد عسكريه هناك وعاوز تستغل
الثروات الطبيعيه هناك الدول ديت محتاجه
اللي انت كنت بتحتلها لعشرات السنوات ثم
ظلاله تستفيد منها العشرات السنوات محتاج
ان يكون اسهامك الحقيقي انك تساعد في
التنميه لكن فكره ان هم يفضلوا كده عباره
عن مغاره علي بابا تاخذ منهم ولا تعطيهم
فالطبيعي ان الامور تسوء وفي الدول
بتستفيد من توتر العلاقه ديت اللي هي
روسيا علشان تحل محلها يعني
سيدنا
سامحني مش مش فاهم بتقوله ده برده اخونا
مثل ما عرفش يعني ايه سامحني استاذ سيد
لماذا تصر الحكومه المصريه على عدم الخروج
من الاقتصاد وترك القطاع الخاص ومساندته
وتشجيعه رغم الفشل فيه السياسه الماليه
واداره اصول وموارد الدوله هي الدوله ده
المهندس محمد او انجنير احمد الدوله كان
عندها وجهه نظر
في 2014 2015 وبتقول انا عاوز اعيد بناء
الدوله كله وكلا مشروع الدنيا تحتيها ضخمه
والقطاع الخاص لن يهتم كثيرا بالدخول في
هذه المشروعات اللي هي عاوزها مليارات
مليارات الدولارات والعائد طويل الامد
وشركات القطاع الاعمال حالتها لا يسر عدو
ولا حبيب قليل منه فانا هدخل انا كدوله
بشركات جديده وبشركات الجيش الى اخره كان
في منطق او على الاقل وجهه نظر معموله بس
كان طوال الوقت الجدل ده كان موجود انت
ادخل كدوله بمؤسسات القوات المسلحه وغيرها
والشركات اللي انت بتعملها بايد وبتحاول
تساعد القطاع الخاص بحيث انه يوما ما وهو
يعني مش قادر انه يقدر يقدر تمشي المساله
انا بدخل دلوقتي الى ان يستطيع القطاع
الخاص ان يكون قادرا على المشاركه ما حدث
ان الدوله
اولا
نشاطها لم يقتصر على فتره محدده لفتره
طالت جدا ثم كل يوم زاد مشاركه الدوله
بشكل كبير جدا بحيث انه تقريبا ما عادش في
يعني غير مساحه محدوده للقطاع الخاص طبعا
ده مش راي الدوله بتقول انا كل المشروعات
بعملها بالقطاع الخاص والله وجهات نظري
يعني مسالتين محتاجين مناقشه يعني انما في
كل الاحوال حان الوقت الوقت ده مش هيكون
قرار اداري لا عمليه صعبه
وبيترتب على مشاركه اجهزه الدوله ان في
شركات وفي مراكز قانونيه وفي مستفيدين مش
مش سهل يعني مش قرار اداري ادخل ادخل اخرج
اخرج ولكن في وثيقه ملكيه الدوله وفي
افكار كثيره والموقف المعلن الرسمي اننا
سوف نتخرج من اكبر عدد ممكن وبداوا
فلننتظر ونرى يعني
اخونا سامي
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا كثر الف خيرك ماذا يعني
وصف ملك المغرب في خطابه الاخير ان علاقات
المغرب اجابنا هل تعرف سعد الفقيه وكلامه
على الشان السعودي
لا والله اسمع الاسم باعتباره معارض
السعودي لكن لم اتابع اخبره من فتره طويله
السلام عليكم انا جابر اجبت يا صديقي جابر
ما اخر مستجدات اجابنا هل هناك
هل اردوغان يسعى لتحسين اجابنا
[موسيقى]
السودان
سامحني لم افهم الكلمه الاولى او اي سي مش
فاهم السلام عليكم من السعوديه لجميع
المشاهدين نشكرك يا اخونا سامي
سيدنا
لم افهم استاذ السيد لماذا يعتبر جواد
السفر البصري من اضعف جوازات السفر في
المنطقه العربيه والعالم
وتتقدمه بلد افريقيه في الترتيب مثل
اوغندا وزامبيا وتونس والمغرب وما هي
المعايير التي تحدد قوه جواد السفر ما
عنديش معلومه عن مساله الترتيب والمؤشر
التواضح انت بتتكلم على مؤشر معين
والمناسبه قبل ما اجاوب قبل ما احاول
اجاوب على سؤالك يعني المؤشرات ديت بتبقى
يعني مش يعني كل حاجه تقريبا تحولت الى
مؤشرات وراها مركز بيعملها وبصدر المؤشر
سنويا وبيزنس حلو يعني مش ضروري تكون
دقيقه قوي انما لو افترضنا الدقه في هذا
المؤشر الذي لا اتابعه يعني عاده جواز
السفر بيحمل مجموعه من الامور المنطقيه كل
دوله عاوزه لما تستقبل حد من دوله اخرى
انه يكون اضافه لها كسائح او
كمستثمر ما هو لاجئ مش مرحب به الا اذا
كان يعني في شروط محدوده جدا
انه هجره شرعيه لازم يكون كفاءه تضيف الى
البلد فاذا جنبنا المسائل ديت واتكلمنا عن
الاستثمار وبتكلمنا على السياحه لازم يكون
انت عندك يعني ما تضيفه الى البلد
وبالتالي كلما كان اقتصاد البلد كبير
ونصيب الافراد من هذا الاقتصاد الكبير
تقدر تخرج سياحه هتقدر تخرج
كمستثمر ليه بيرحبوا بجواز السفر القطري
وما بيرحبوش اوائد السفر المصري لان
القطريين دوله غنيه اللي هيخرج هناك هينفك
كثيرا في الدوله اللي ذاهب بها كسائح او
كمستثمر وده مش هينطبق على الغالبيه من
المصريين ثم نتيجه الاقتصاد المتواضع
بيبقى غالبا اللي هيخرج من هذه الدوله
هيكون او في عدد كبير من اللي عاوزين
يذهبوا تحت اي ستار من الاستثمار او
السياحه علشان يستقر هناك وبالتالي يسبب
المتاعب انت عاوز تسال بقى على حاجه
تحديدا طب ما في دول اخرى لا يحتاج بقى
المؤشر المؤشر عامل ايه مؤشر بيحط معايير
ممكن يبقى مدن دي 65 ودي 64 يعني بتبقى
حاجات على حسب طبيعه المؤشر والشركه اللي
عاملاها والمؤسسه اللي عاملاها يعني انما
دي المعايير العامه ايه رايك بالصحافي
خالد الراشد وببرمجه رحله في الذاكره وهل
هو موجه من البروباندا الروسيه
والمعلومات غايه في الاهميه وخاصه في
التاريخ السوفيتي والحربين العالميه
الاولى والثانيه وراي حضرتك بيهمنا والله
الخالد راشد اللي بيقدم برامج على ار تي
بيقدم برامج قيمه انا الحاجه بس اللي
بتزعجني في هذا البرنامج وبرامج اخرى على
ار تي هي الترجمه اللي بيبقى معها الراجل
بيتكلم باقي بنفس صعوبه اتمنى اما بما ان
هو بيتكلم لغه لا نعلمها مثلا روسي او
غيره او حتى بيتكلمها بس
يتم اسكات الصوت علشان نسمع لان انا مع
الاتنين اجت صعوبه في اننا المتابعه
الحقيقيه لكن الحاجات اللي بتهمني اجد ان
هو بيستضيف البرنامج اولا من البرامج
الهادفه المهمه لكن بالاضافه لانه من
البرامج الهادفه او البرامج الدسمه يعني
انه بيقدم لنا نوعيه مش متاحه لان هو
بيركز كتير على تاريخ روسيا والاتحاد
السوفيتي لانه البرامج اللي بتركز على
التاريخ الغربي والتاريخ الامريكي كثيره
فهو برنامج نوعي ومفيد وجيد اتمنى بس لو
كان حد من اذا كان هو خالد او اي حد من
برنامج وبيسمعنا يكون مشكورا يراعه ده
سواء وفي سواء في هذا البرنامج او غيره
بتبقى عمليه مشوشه جدا انت بتسالني بقى
احنا بنتكلم على الاهميه هل هو موجه
انا ما اقدرش احكم بس بما ان هو في ار تي
فهو برنامج بيعبر عن
التوجهات الروسيه صعب انه يجيب ده ويشتم
في روسيا لكن حتى لو موجه يعني مش لازم
يكون موجه عكسه انه هو محايد ممكن يقدر
يحتفظ لنفسه بمساحه جيده وكويسه ما تكونش
لا بتطبل ولا بتهاجم روسيا الحاليه انا ما
لاحظتش ده خالص يعني ما لاحظتوش في
الحلقات اللي انا تابعتها وانا ما بتابعش
بقى لي فتره لاسباب تتعلق بيا مش
بالبرنامج انما
حتى لو برنامج منحاز ما انت متلقي انت
بتحاول تفهم وتحذف الجزء ده يعني تقول ده
بيقدم حاجه مفيده لكن طبعا ده محسوب على
روسيا فانا ادقق في المعلومات دي محتاج
تعمل لانه كل واحد عنده مش كل واحد معظم
الناس عندها عشان
هل اللغه العربيه في خطر
جيش اجابه يعني اختلف عن غيري احساس نعم
لكن انا يعني مش
احساسي نعم احنا عندنا اولادنا ما بيعرفوش
عربي اصلا يعني وكل جيل من الطبقه
المتوسطه والطبقه الاعلى اولادهم ما
بيعرفوش عربي صح يا ماندو
ما حدش بيعرف عربي
انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك على حاجه انا اولادي
دلوقتي في سن اللي هو 22 يعني من 19 ل 22
لما كانوا صغيرين
كنت بجيب لهم كتب واخدهم للمكتبات الكبيره
يستعينوا منها كتب
فكنت بعمل ايه
الكتب الانجليزيه الاول بدات بجوايز
تعملهاش قيمه هم اصلا حابين القرايه بس
لاحظت بعد فتره انه كل الكتب اللي بيقول
كلها كلها بلا استثناء باللغه الانجليزيه
فقلت لا انا هدي جائزه لكل من يقرا حاجه
باللغه العربيه
والله ما دفعت مليم واحد من هذه الجوائز
يعني كان لسان حالهم ما هم حطت لنا من
جوائز هم طبعا كانوا اطفال مش هيقولوا لي
كده لكن الكتاب بيفضل لي موجود يعني زي ما
هو فانا ما دفعتش حاجه خالص ابتديت ابحث
عن القصه كده ايه السبب يعني ان اطفال
اغريهم بجوائز وهم يقراوش برضو انه
المحتوى العربي فعلا فقير وانت لما بتحاول
تكتب حاجه للاطفال بتحاول ان انت بس تبقى
سخيف يعني تقول قالت ديكو للفرخه والفخ
لكن هو المضمون سخيف مش ان انت لما ترسم
صوره ديك وتشيكن
وبقره وبتاع يبقى كده وجدت انه المضمون
اما تافه هي ضعيف يا سخيف لا يغرب القراءه
ده على مستوى الاطفال وعلى مستوى الكبار
معظم الكتب اما عباره عن مقالات صحفي جمع
مقالاته قعد كتابتها كتاب او باحث كان
بيتقدماجستير او دكتوراه وراح عمل الكتاب
مره تانيه او عم له كتاب بس في كتب مميزه
قليله بس لكن مفيش كتير وبالتالي
اللغه العربيه في خطر لانه المحتوى العربي
لا يقرا لا يضيف فهي جزء من ازمه اكبر اما
باللغه الانجليزيه او طبعا اللغات الاخرى
التي لا اعرفها فانت بتلاقي كل شيء من اول
كتب للاطفال وانا المايك وكان الصوت واضح
الصوت واضح يا شباب انه كل حاجه كل شيء
موجود الاصل للروايات الكبيره اللي هي
مكتوبه باللغه الانجليزيه اصلا او باي لغه
وترجمه اللغه الانجليزيه كاصل او
مختصره او نصف مختصره كل شيء موجود الكتب
العلميه الكتب الادبيه الكتب الفلسفيه
كيف سوف يكون البث بيقطع البث بيقطع يا
صديقي
ده قديم يا هاني مش كده
على طول ماندو زي الحكومه المصريه قال لك
ما فيش اي مشاكل نقول الحكومه ان نور
بيقطع ابدا انتم اللي مش واخدين بالكم
انتم مش عارفين تفتحوا النور
ينفع رئيس حكومه قال لك ابدا ما فيش بس
بيقطع ولا حاجه انت ما خدتش بالك
ماذا يعني وصف ملك المغرب عجبنا كيف سيكون
موقف المجتمع الدولي اذا قامت الصين كان
هستاذنكم اقف عند الساعه 11
كيف سيكون موقف المجتمع الدولي اذا قامت
الصين بغزو تايوان باعتبارها ارض صينيه
باعتراف امريكا نفسها ده ابو عبد
عبود اخونا عبد يعني عبود الجزء الثاني ما
هو السؤال ده اقترح انا فاكر جوزيف نايل
اللي هو يعني استاذ علوم سياسيه مشهور في
امريكا اللي هو بتاع السوفت باور اللي
اخترع مفهوم او تور مفهوم القوه الناعمه
لما كان الصينيين بيسالوها هتعملوا ايه لو
غزانا قال لهم والله انتم مش عارفين واحنا
كمان كامريكان مش عارفين المساله كلها
تتوقف متى سوف تفعلون ذلك في اي ظروف سوف
تقومون بالغزو وفي اي ظروف سوف تكون
الولايات المتحده لانه المساله يعني فكره
ان امريكا تخاطر بحرب مع
الصين مساله هتبقى تتوقف على الظروف في اي
ظروف الممكن يحصل الغزو وامريكا ما يتعملش
حاجه او تكتفي بان هي تعمل زي ما عملت مع
الروسي ان هي تصلح طيران مسلحه حتى حتى
اذنيها يعني فلا احد يستطيع ان يقطع
باجابه وقبل السيد بيضن كانت دائما
الاجابات يعني غامضه بيضا بس هو الاربع
مرات سوف نتحرك عسكريا لكن البيت الابيض
صلح تصريحاته
يعني تضرب الصين مثلا يعني
لماذا تطرح البنوك المركزيه اجابنا
كم حجم التبادل التجاري بين الولايات
المتحده والصين مئات المليارات لكن انا
محتاج ان انا ارجع للرقم صباح الخيرات
استاذ سيد بعد اذنك ممكن نناقش مشاكل
فرنسا الداخليه والخارجيه خصوصا بعد خساره
نفوذه في كل من طب ايه رايكم يعني قبل ما
نتكلم عن فرنسا نعمل حلقه عن منطقه الساحل
لو موافقين نعملها الاسبوع المقبل ان شاء
الله انا دايما عاوز اعمل حاجه عن الساحل
والصراع اللي موجود عليه ومنها الوضع وضع
فرنسا في افريقيا وبعد كده نتكلم على
فرنسا ان شاء الله اليس من الياس من
كاليفورنيا تشرفت يا اخونا الياس مشاكل
فرنسا الداخليه والخارجيه نبدا بالساحل ثم
ان شاء الله نتكلم على
فرنسا من الافضل اللغه من الافضل اللغه
الانجليزيه ام اللغه الفرنسيه بالنسبه
للدول المغرب العربي افضل ايه يا صديقي
لغه كبار لو عندك القدره تعرفهم جدا انا
كنت اتمنى اعرف لغه غير اللغه الانجليزيه
ولكن لم تسمح الظروف بذلك ولما سمحت انا
كنت مشغول بتعلم مهارات اخرى يعني يعني
بقت لان غالبا اللي بيعرف انجليزي
الدنيا كلها مفتحه اللغه اللغه الفرنسيه
لغه عظيمه فلو تقدر تعرف الاتنين اهلا
وسهلا لو بتتكلم على بالنسبه لدول المغرب
العربي اللغه الفرنسيه لغه شائعه انما اذا
كنت ما بتعرفش فرنساوي وانت في المغرب
العربي تتعلم الفرنسيه وحاول تاخد فكره
على الانجليزي يعني هل تتوقع ان الانقلاب
في النيجر سوف تتاثر به الازمه السودانيه
والصراع في ليبيا ده هي كل حاجه بتاثر على
حاجه انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك على حاجه
ركز معي هل كنت تسمع عن مشاكل الساحل قبل
2012 واخر 2011
الاجابه لا المشاكل كانت موجوده طبعا دول
عندها مشاكل انما المشاكل بدات تظهر
للعيان امتى لما بدات تسقط نظام معمر
القذافي المشركين في معمر القذافي الفكره
في ان كانت فيه دوله مهمه موجوده مستقره
بتلعب دور مع او ضد ضد هذه الدول يعني
بتلعب دور ما مره بالسلب ومره بالايجاب
انما كان في سقط النظام في في ليبيا بدا
يبقى في فراغ سلطه بدا يبقى في تسرب سلاح
بدا السلاح يتسرب من ليبيا يذهب الى دول
اخرى وبالتالي سقوط ليبيا اثر على الفوضى
اللي موجوده وقتها في مالي بدايه من 2012
ثم من مالي باقي دول افريقيا بقى في فرصه
للجماعات المتطرفه ان هي تنشط
وتنطلق من ليبيا وتؤثر على تشاد وتؤثر على
النيجر وبوركينا فاسو الى اخره بديهي ان
اي فوضى ولو تحولت الفوضى الى حرب سوف
تؤثر على الجزائر والمغرب لا قدر الله بقى
وليبيا وتونس ودول غرب افريقيا
الى اخره
اخر هناك هناك اعجبنا
اتوقع ان الفلسطينيين بيحصل عندك تقطيع في
البث لا ده مش واحد بس مساء الخيرات يمكن
يكون برضه طيب توقعنا الفلسطينيين لم
يرغبوا وليسوا جاهدين لقيام دوله فلسطينيه
ده عليه ممكن يا علي يكونوا مش جاهزين
انما ما يرغموش بتاء صعبه انا استاذنكم
صوره مشوشه ده
كوتشى بيقول مشوشه يمكن في الاول كله برضه
طيب ممكن انا بقى
من ساعه طيب
البث كان اليوم سيء الله ده كتير اهو سمر
ممكن حلقه عن تاثير العالم مديون لمين ما
احنا نكتفي بالاجابه السؤال الاخير اذا
كان البث سيء اليوم سامحونا الاول انا
بعدين اتكلم على البث السيء العالم يقول
لي مين يا صديقي
اجمالي الناتج المحلي للعالم حوالي 100
تريليون يعني اجمالي ما ينتجه العالم من
سلع وخدمات مقوما
مقوما بالاموال حوالي 100 تريليون الديون
المترتبه على دول العالم حاول 350 تريليون
ده معناها ايه معناها مجموعه من الامور
واحد قاعده انه الدين انه الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي ده بيقاس من سنه لسنه ان ماديا
ممكن يتاخد سنتين تلاته اربعه والعشرين
سنه فالمعيار مش دقيق قوي اثنين ان في دول
بتطبع اموال كثيره
وفكر اليونات الدولارات اللي بتطبعها
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي اكثر
مما ينتج وبالتالي الاموال ديت بتستدنها
الشركات وبتستدنها الافراد
وبتستد دول ناشئه اخرى ولذلك الدول الدول
العالم مدين مدين لافراده اللي هم بيدخروا
في البنوك ما دين لدول اخرى اصرفت في
الطباعه ولكن عملتها محله ثقه وبس فالعالم
مدين لنفسه السؤال اللي بتساله ايه تاني
احنا استاذنكم
توقف عند هذا القدر انا عارف ان في اسئله
اخرى كثيره انا اسف جدا لو كان احنا
تاخرنا عليكم في البث احنا بدانا بعد
التسعه ونص بس والله خارج عن ارادتنا بسبب
سياسه تخفيف الاحمال اللي موجوده في
القاهره اللي احنا عايشين فيها واذا كان
البث السيء ربما لان انا ارتبكنا
مش عارف السبب يعني احنا برضو كنا نعم
يعني
يمكن نتيجه مشاكل مشكله الشبكه الكهرباء
فسامحونا نتمنى ان شاء الله انه المرات
الجايه يكون الوضع اكثر استقرارا وبالتالي
تكون البث افضل وكان اعتذاري وان شاء الله
نلقاكم الاسبوع المقبل وطبعا بعتذر عن
الاسئله اللي ما لحقناهاش لكن احنا
هنلتقيكم الاسبوع الجاي اذا ربنا احيانا
اكون في فرصه اخرى اشكركم الى اللق